hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Aristotle asks us what is a friend and
this is something that we don't often
think too much about and when we do
think about it
we tend to think about it much more in
terms of like an individual relation
between two people is this person really
my friend or not and we don't think
about it in the big broad Universal
strokes if we have to say what being a
friend means to somebody who might ask
us like imagine that a child you're
babysitting somebody maybe they bring up
hey I don't know what a friend is you
know this person seems like a friend but
I'm not quite sure you probably wouldn't
put together a list what else would you
but this is what Aristotle does why does
he do this well sometimes if we want to
understand something that's important in
our lives our moral lives as a whole we
have to look for all the common features
and this is an idealized picture of what
it means to be a friend not everything
that we call friendship necessarily has
this so let's look at each of these each
of these what would you call criteria
how to define friendships so he starts
off by telling a good
we'll what is that that means that you
wish well for the other person you want
good things for them you want them to be
well you want them to do well
you want them to prosper he'll get a
little bit more specific about that in
another place this first one is from a
book eight of the naked mechanics so he
says Goodwill felt towards each other
reciprocal reciprocal II that means that
if I am actually friends with you it's
not enough that I feel goodwill towards
you you also have to feel goodwill
towards me and he points out that we
often feel goodwill towards people who
don't necessarily feel it towards us so
for example think about sports teams how
many of you like to watch on
professional or amateur or what I will
be between semi-pro sports okay so by
the after class do you like some of the
people that you watch do you feel good
feelings towards them or do you don't
care at all it's just about you know
whether the team wins or loses I think
most of you actually forego some degree
of goodwill towards them and it might
vary depending on the cat person you
know if they're if they're losing then
you might quit feeling goodwill towards
them right because the sport seems we
want people to do well if they're the
underdog and they succeed you might feel
a massive amount of goodwill towards
them if you know that they're involved
with good activities outside of the
arena then you might feel more goodwill
towards them if you find out that they
are doing bad things
you know once they get out of the locker
room then that could go Mike might
disappear but does that athlete feel
towards know what if you write them Sam
water no that's not enough
why not why doesn't that yet
yeah you're exactly right this there's a
time we have a fan clock right because
people are famous enough that they're
getting tons and tons of letters emails
gifts from other people they can't
possibly reciprocate everybody else and
you're just sort of one drop in an
entire ocean of people you can think
about this room musical performance to
write or actors and actresses famous
professors you know I could write to
Peter Singer or who else might be of
that stature that people like know well
a guy who read through the New York
Times Simon Critchley it was quite the
same stature I can write to them odds
are they ever going to write back
probably not are we going to hang out on
the weekend and talk philosophy we have
philosophy in common
probably not right because they have a
lot of other things to do the good will
he has to be reciprocal sometimes you
have people who like you but you don't
like down in the back you're not friends
according to Aristotle they have good
will towards you but that's not enough
too many friends there has to be that
felt towards each other's reciprocity
the friends have to be aware of their
mutual good one they have to actually
see themselves as in some sort of
relationship with each other
at least on some sort of not necessarily
like you know explicitly formulating it
saying ah we are now friends but you
know feeling towards each other life
that feeling is there and if that's
missing they're not going to be friends
for much longer there's cause for this
this goodwill some sort of perceived
good and that's that's why I thought
this this whole chart over here and
we're going to talk about these three
types of goods and these three types of
friendship
shortly so very very quickly you can
friendships in terms of who the person
really is because they're a good person
and you admire them you like them for
their own sake
some people are pleasant you enjoy being
with them because they give you pleasure
and then there's some friendships
Aristotle says where you're just getting
something out of the person hopefully
they're getting something out of you and
it's not because you really like the
person it's not because they're pleasant
it's because perhaps they open doors for
you
I don't mean just you know open doors
like physical course figurative doors
they they have contents for you this is
about usefulness and here's a place
where aerosol is going to differ from
say cut remember constant never use a
person merely as a means Aristotle would
say well there's certain kinds of
friendship we do use each other as this
means and that can be to some degree
okay but there has to be some sort of
perceived good if you don't see anything
in the relationship with a person you
can't be friends with them they can't be
friends with you he adds a few other
things as well
the front wishes well and promotes by
actions that good for the other
there's keep two things that are key
here for the sake of the other so not
just to get something else out of it
like to look like they're a big you know
big shot or something like that but
because they actually want something
good for the other person now this is
the you know full type of friendship and
we would say if your won't buy the
action if you feel nice towards somebody
and they feel nice towards you but you
never do anything actually to improve
their life to help them out to make them
happy and they never do anything towards
you in the same respect
are you really friends you have good
feelings towards each other you like
each other aren't even friends if
neither one of you ever does anything
what do you think
does that make sense to us to talk that
way so here's one way you might think
about this what is probably the most
trivial thing that you could do to show
somebody that you like that in some
respect
how about liking one of their posts on
Facebook does that mean anything here
and it means something right does it
mean anything big when you like
somebody's post on Facebook
dude when you when you put a post and
somebody we haven't talked to for years
something likes it do you feel oh we're
now real friends now what do you feel
yeah right another another like added to
it maybe there's already el34 people who
knows how much you like it if your
relationship is just liking each other's
Facebook posts you're really not friends
are you Facebook all your friends
there used to actually be another thing
before Facebook what was it called whose
friends something or other and Facebook
ham cook over the idea from that kind of
smart because it makes you feel like
you're connected to people but are you
really connected to people unless you're
interacting with them and what if you
comment on some of these clothes and you
don't have it just by saying you know
lol or that's really stupid or yes or
something like that but you actually
really comment on their post and you say
that's a thoughtful remark on your part
I'm so glad you posted it are you doing
something good by action yeah
is it is it earth-shaking is that going
to change anybody's life well if it does
they're pretty hard up aren't they
that's going to be the one thing that
tilts you know their life from the bad
you know balance to them to the good
balance what are the sort of things that
friends actually do for each other what
do you do for your friends promoting
their well-being my action
what do you do all of you have friends
let's call what did what do you do with
your friends yeah I like that right yeah
and if you quit doing that they would
their life wouldn't be as this full what
else whatever you do at your friends
play sports outside so you engage in
activity planned activity or impromptu
activity what else do we do well your
friends do for you yeah that's a big one
you know if you learn how to cook taking
classes up with the culinary smart thing
to do is if you can cook for people they
love that and you know each of us is
barbecuing it's one of the simplest
forms of cooking around if you buy the
tip if you're shelling out without the
things if you're giving your friends
nice things that's that's promoting your
well being my action didn't you
recommend books music movies to each
other why do you do that yeah because
they're similar interests and I know if
I like it the most
yeah you like your friends to be happy
so if you recommend something to them do
you think it's going to make them happy
then you're doing them a good favor
right I mean they're you don't always
have to be do it hard or you know
getting your friend out of jail or pick
whatever up see like that's kind of
momentous in order to be a good friend
you just have to be doing some sort of
action and they're very often trivial
that's hanging out with people that is
doing something listening to people
instead of tuning them out and saying
I'm going to check my phone right now
and text somebody else that's promoting
somebody's good bye ash another thing
that it talks about particularly in
terms of family members wishing
existence or preservation of the other
for the other sync and this is kind of
an interesting way to think about things
Aristotle defines hatred the opposite of
friendship has the wish that the other
person not even exists feeling like they
have no right to be with friendship it's
recognizing that this is a better world
that this person is in it you want them
to continue in their VA being involved
with each other the hanging out thing
has to do with this you know mutual
activities you have to be involved with
each other you have to share sometime
you have to share some some physical
space Aristotle thinks you have to be in
proximity with each other not all the
time but at least a good portion of the
time that's why hanging out is actually
such an important thing we see that as
very trivial about me but if you're not
willing to spend time sitting next to
your friend even if you're not actually
doing anything particularly important
you're not really friends now can we
always do this or that or is it possible
for us to be friends
people that are at a distance social
media is kind of helped out with that
has to overcome distance because email
somebody Skype them Facebook you know I
don't you guys just Twitter or not but I
suppose you can use Twitter for that as
well
LinkedIn probably not quite so much
that's more of a professional networking
thing that's why they're called contacts
not friends but doing things together
that's not only how friendship forms
that's how friendship continuous and
that's how function grows you get to
know people by doing things with them
including you right sit down and eat
with people you get to know who they are
you start telling stories about
themselves desiring the same things if
you really want to be friends with
somebody it's not enough just to make
each other happy you actually have to
share desires that come you have to see
the same things as valuable you have to
have the same set of priorities doesn't
mean you have to agree on everything you
know even if you agreed to disagree
that's a kind of agreement right you say
I value our friendship I value being
around you more than seeing eye-to-eye
with you on religion or politics or who
should win American Idol or start
picking more and more trivial things
which TV show is better that's still be
having some common desires the desire to
preserve the relationship isn't it and
then finally sharing joys and sorrows is
this usually how we think of friendship
you guys think of friendship that that
way at your age you know your early
twenties sharing joys and sorrows that
will become much more important to you
as time goes on as you have many more
very important joys and sorrows because
your life large part the things that are
valuable in your life are going to give
you joy and when they're taken away
those are going to be sorrows and when
you have friends and they actually do
share in your sorrows when somebody dies
for example and they come to console you
where you lose your job god forbid or
not if you ever do lose your job but you
know may happen they come to console you
you guys are probably more attune to a
different kind of loss that you've
probably encountered multiple times at
this point what would that be that not
bad grades but that's a little bit more
trivial what's one thing that could
really screw up your life at least
feeling wise when you break up with
somebody or they break up with you right
and who do you want to hang out with at
that point if you want to hang out your
friends right you want to just go to
some place where nobody knows you or
would you rather be with somebody who
you can actually talk to about it if you
want to talk or just sit in silence and
play xbox together and feel a little bit
better about things that sharing in joys
and sorrows these are all components of
real friendship for the dearest